I just didn't feel like we played with
the same urgency the same tenacity the
same toughness we didn't set the edge
the same as we had been earlier the
season and you know it's disappointing
because it's not like we didn't know
what they were gonna try to do we knew
exactly what they were gonna try to do
we knew they were gonna run football and
for them to be able to to do that was
extremely disappointing and I just
didn't think we played with this the
same effort as what I had seen earlier
in the season Matt Lafleur from
Wednesday meeting with reporters in the
aftermath of the loss to the San
Francisco 49ers that entered the pack
for season 14 and for not a bad first
season for Matt Lafleur but Chrissy
wasn't happy with how the defense played
and during that press conference he
suggested that in the way it was
interpreted was that maybe Mike Pettine
wouldn't be back for a third season with
the team remember he predated Matt
Lafleur he was a holdover from the Mike
McCarthy staff later in the day it was
announced that peten would be back for
another season hey I mean Lafleur is
right they knew what was coming yeah but
if you just physically can't stop it it
doesn't matter if you know it's coming
what great yeah well there's so many
things that factor first of all the
49ers are a Super Bowl team you know
second off we saw them in person right
how crazy and loose they can be before a
football game I mean Rodney Harrison and
on the pregame show right last week when
we were there for the Minnesota Vikings
James was like concerned he was like I
II I was on one of the greatest teams in
the history of football we were never
this confident before games you know I
think he was taken back by about it
taken back by it but Shanahan has
created a culture there one by his
scouting and the kind of players he get
there and Mike we've had this
conversation you know he's got a bunch
of guys that just like he says run
through the wall and they run through
the wall they don't think about like the
consequences or anything they just go
coach told me to run through it here I
go zoom waterboy you know but a lot of
guys in the NFL you tell them to run
through the wall they think about it for
a second and they go okay screw it all
right I'll do it coach yeah and they've
crew they have that attitude the fact
that you know I think you're right
you know there was the 49ers had great
belief they have the intensity of a
Super Bowl team you know I always think
of my dad in 1985 they played the Bears
in the playoff game and he always says
that was the wake-up call that they
realized that they needed to raise their
level intensity another notch for them
to go to the Super Bowl and it helped
them for 98 1986 to do that but I think
this was a team that got blown out by
this team early in the year I think they
went into the game with no confidence
I'm watching the pregame show and I was
thinking the same thing
I was going man San Francisco seems
loose and ready to fly around and Green
Bay seems kind of nervous and reserved
and that to me is on the head coach to
instill that confidence or false
confidence and with whether it's some
game plan plays early to get your role
in whatever it may be but yes they
looked like they were shell-shocked
after the the second Drive of the game
and they went oh no this feels like the
first time we played can we really beat
them and nothing ever gave him the
confidence to get over the hump and
remember it was John Fox who got fired
by the Broncos after a playoff loss
because John Elway the GM of the team
said he wanted to see more of an effort
to go out kicking and screaming when it
was time to lose in the playoffs it was
after they had lost the Colts a few
years ago and you mentioned the impact
on the Giants of losing to the Bears in
the 85 playoffs you know it was the
Bears losing to the 1984 Wright 23 to
nothing right on the plane ride home
that's where the seeds were planted for
the 85 Bears right they were upset that
they got manhandled by the 49ers
that they got shut out by the 49ers and
they were determined that the next year
it was going to be different and I you
know I just wonder how much of Matt
Lafleur's frustration from yesterday is
a combination of one we got our butts
kicked even though we knew what they
were going to try to do and maybe number
two he hasn't detected yet that that
sense of determination that they're
gonna do what they have to do yeah to
compete with the 49ers because you know
Aaron Rodgers after the game when he
looked like he had just come in from
three months out the sea yeah his words
were way too optimistic for the
ass-kicking the Packers had just taken
right
yeah you know I think the window is open
and I think we're gonna be on the right
side of these one of these times soon
not if you have to keep playing the
49ers and they can come out and tell you
what they're gonna do and still do it to
you and you can't stop them
no yeah you're exactly right you know a
green baize had to get tougher up front
of both sides of the ball there's no
doubt about that you know they weren't
as good as past protecting offensive
line as they'd been in years past and
yes they were better in the run game but
not to where why we just go oh my gosh
they're just steamrolling teams every
week no it's not that way so they gotta
get better up front on the offensive
line as we saw in the NFC Championship
game the defensive line as well
I mean hey yes I understand that they
knew the 49ers are gonna run the ball
but this was a defensive line that's not
talented other than the two guys on the
edge you know that's just not that
special knee inside and neither or the
middle linebacker play so they got to
really improve that I mean you're
watching the 49ers and the Kansas City
Chiefs go to the Super Bowl and there
are teams that are have eight and nine
defensive lineman who can play at a time
they can just keep rotating in fresh
bodies green guy can't even do that
so one they were compromised that way
which forced Patton to do things he
didn't want to do and then to yeah you
might have known they were gonna run the
ball but I bet you didn't know Shanahan
was gonna break out some of those plays
and play design to go with it too so
when you have that double whammy to go
along with it that's when you get
steamrolled for like 300 yards and
rushing and this gets back to a point
that I've been kind of working on I've
run it by you through through text and
we talked about it earlier this yeah
there's gonna be a premium placed on
finding guys who are the same level of
bad ass roughneck that the 49ers players
are yeah who don't need to practice
hitting who don't need full pad
two-a-days who don't need tackling to
the ground in July and August when they
can't do it anymore to be able to do it
when it's time to go out and play a game
the 49ers have those guys and other
teams need to be looking for those guys
because if you can't practice it you
better be instinctively wired down do it
right and teams are going to need more
guys like that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports